wir ernten jetzt gerade richtig viele
Tomaten aus dem Garten die können wir
nicht alle essen also werden die Vorräte
direkt für den Winter vorbereitet nehmt
dafür verschiedene Tomaten die schön
reif sind halbiert oder viertelt sie
gebt sie in ein Backblech bisschen
Olivenöl drüber und dann das Ganze ab in
den Ofen bei 180 Grad Heißluft so könnt
ihr mehrere Bleche gleichzeitig backen
ungefähr 30 Minuten die gegrillten
Tomaten nehmen wir dann heraus püriert
sie schön kocht sie noch einmal erneut
auf und gebt sie dann in ausgekochte
sterile Gläser jetzt einfach nur noch
verschließen und bei Bedarf dann eben
verwenden so sind sie mehrere Wochen bis
Monate haltbar